we're on problem 24 a rope 40 feet long
is cut into two pieces let's draw that
a rope 40 feet long is cut into two
pieces let's say that's where i cut them
if one piece
is 18 feet longer than the other what is
the length in feet of the shorter piece
so let's say this is a shorter piece
this is the longer piece
x plus
18.
and they also tell us that both pieces
combine it's a 40 foot long rope so if i
add these together it should be equal to
40. so x plus x plus 18 is equal to 40.
x plus x is equal to 2x
plus 18 is equal to 40.
and then i get 2x is equal to subtract
18 from both sides that's what 22
x is equal to 11.
next problem let me switch colors
25.
the earth travels around the sun at a
speed of approximately 18.5
18.5
miles per second
miles
per second
this approach this approximate speed is
how many miles per hour so how many
seconds are there in a mile so you have
seconds per minute
and then you have times 60 minutes
per hour
so you get 60 times 60 is 3600 and the
units work out too minutes in the
denominator minutes in the numerator so
you get 3 600 seconds per hour
so 18 and a half miles per second you're
going to go 3 600 times as far in an
hour so let's multiply that times 3 600
seconds
per hour
and you'll get whatever this number is
so let's multiply it out 18.5
i'm going to multiply it times 36 and
then add two zeros later
six times five is thirty
six times eight is forty eight plus
three is fifty one
six times one is six plus five is eleven
three times five is fifteen
three times eight is twenty-four plus
one is twenty-five
three times one is three plus two is
five
and so you get a zero
a six a six and a six
and then i have one number behind the
decimal point so 18 and a half times 36
is 666
but then if i'm but i'm multiplying that
by 36 would buy 3600 so 18 and a half
times 3 600 is going to be equal to this
times 100 so
600 and the units work out second in the
denominator second in the numerator
miles
per hour and that's choice d and they
didn't even let you approximate it
because choice c is really close you
really had to as far as i can tell go
through the multiplication
next problem
26 if the quotient a over b is positive
a over b
is positive that's what they're telling
us which of the following must be true
must be true so if a over b is positive
that tells us that essentially tells us
that a and b have to have the same sign
right the only way you can get a
positive number when you divide two
numbers is if they're both positive
both positive or they're both negative
if they were different signs if one was
positive and one was negative or one was
negative one was positive then this
would be a negative number so this tells
us that they're the same sign
so statement a
choice a
tells us
a is greater than zero no this doesn't
have to be true they both could be less
than
zero b tells us that b is greater than
0. once again this isn't necessarily
true they both could be less than 0 and
this would still be true
choice c
a b is greater than 0.
well think about it we said this implies
that both a and b have to have the same
sign
if a and b have the same sign when i
multiply them i'm still going to get a
number bigger than zero right a positive
times a positive is a positive a
negative times a negative is a positive
so let's choice c
problem 27 and i saw this coming so i
drew
this ahead of time
actually no i didn't well let me
let me
i thought i had drawn it ahead of time
let me actually open it up
let me thought i
i thought i had drawn it oh it must have
gotten erased well let's just do it in
real time then
so it says the dots on the graph above
indicate the weights and fuel efficiency
ratings for 20 cars
how many of the cars weigh more than
2500 pounds
so 27. how many so weight
is more than 2500
weight is more than 2500
and also get more than 25 miles per
gallon so fuel efficiency
is
more than 22 miles per gallon
and notice they said more than 22 not 22
miles or more and they said more than
2500 not 2500 pounds or more
and if i look at the graph let me just
draw the the part of the graph that
seems relevant
so if that's the
weight axis
so
they have a couple at 25
26 27 28 29 30.
and then we want to know above
above
22. so let me let me actually draw all
of it so that's 25
i'm only drawing part of the graph
because i don't want to go through the
exercise because i actually already did
it and i can't find it all of a sudden
but i don't want to stop recording this
video
so 20
and this is
this is 24. they don't label the 22 on
the
on on their drawing this is 20
this is 26.
this is 28.
and so they want to know all everything
that weighs more than 2500 pounds so
if i were everything to the right of
that because all of these tend to be on
on on um integer numbers they're not
like any none of them are in between and
they say
and get more than 22 miles per gallon so
get more than 22 miles per gallon so let
me draw all of the ones that apply there
so let's see at 26 hundred pounds
there's two
at 24 and 26 miles per gallon
so 26 there's
there's one
at 2600 there's two points right there
at 2700 there are three
points
one
two but the other one falls below the
the 22 mile per gallon the 22 or it
falls on the 22 miles per gallon but
we're talking about it greater than that
and then let's see that's 26 27 28 has
one down here and one up here when i say
28 i mean 2 800 pounds i'm just trying
to draw it for you
and then the rest of them there's two
here and there's one here but all we
care about is the ones in this there's a
bunch more over here i could draw them
real fast if you want me to just so you
can visualize the graph
so it looks something like that
and then there's one more here i'm not
going to pay much you know there's a
bunch but all we care is this range
there's one two three four five five of
those so the answer is b a lot of work
for a fairly straightforward problem
let me get some clean space
problem 28
how many minutes does it take john to
type y words
y words
if he types at a rate of x words
per minute
now this is a fairly straightforward
thing but it can get confusing to divide
by x by y y by x i think it a lot of
times this becomes a lot simpler if you
just pick numbers so if i if we just
phrase it if we said that he needs to
type how long does it take him to type
100 words
if he can type
i don't know 50
words per minute
now your brain would say oh if i can do
50 words per minute it's going to take
me 2 minutes to do 100 words and how did
you get 2 minutes you said 100
divided by 50.
so if you can if you need to type y
words and you can type it x words per
minute the answer is
y divided by x
and that is choice
see that's not one of the choices
but i think they've made a mistake
because this is a simple enough problem
that i have conviction and if you look
at the choices choice a and choice b at
least in the book i have they wrote x
over y so i think that's a typo one of
those probably should have been read one
of those probably should have read y
over x so i'm going to stick by my
answer i think this is another mistake
in the book
y over x you might want to check the
answer key just to make sure but i'm i
mean this
i i have no doubt in my conviction on
this one
and well let me see do i have time for
the next one
well sure
problem 29 i'm running out of space
29.
the square root this is just to make
sure you know how to do square roots of
16 times 20 in order of operations plus
8 times
so there's a bunch of ways we could we
could think about this but the easiest
way instead of doing all of the
multiplication let's see if we can
factor 16 out of both of these numbers
and i'm just you can multiply them out
and try to figure out the square root
it'll take you a long time
so if we rewrite this as 16
times
plus what
this could also be written if we took
this is
this has
32 is 16 times 2 right 16 times 2
right
so 8 times 32 is the same thing as 8
times 16 times 2 which is the same thing
as 16 times 16
right so we could have rewritten this 8
times 32 is 16 times 16. so if we're
factoring a 16 out that's 16 times 20
plus 16
right if you were to just multiply this
out it'd be 16 times 20 plus 16 times 16
which is the same thing as 8 times 32
and i'm doing all of this you could just
do the math yourself but it takes a lot
of time if you don't have a calculator
well now you can say well this is the
same thing as the square root of
16 times the square root of twenty plus
sixteen
well this is plus or minus four although
i don't think they're going to make us
worry about the negative square root so
let's just say it's four looking at the
choices everything's positive so it's
four times and then what's this the
square root of 36
so it's 4 times
that equals 4 times 6 which is equal to
24 and that's choice
b
see you in the next video